keiko fujimori representando a la
derecha autoritaria y pedro castillo el
candidato de extrema izquierda y
sorpresa de las elecciones del 11 de
abril pasarán a la segunda vuelta en
perú como virtuales ganadores
bajo el lema del reencuentro de los
peruanos fujimori agradeció a sus
electores la confianza puesta en ella y
aseguró que no caería en ataques ni en
la campaña del miedo
[Música]
la debilidad
decir claramente que de ninguna manera
voy a hacer caso a esas recomendaciones
y la candidata que se postula a la
presidencia por tercera vez está siendo
investigada por presuntos aportes
ilegales a sus campañas del 2011 y del
2016 por lo que la fiscalía le pide 30
años de cárcel en el frente opuesto el
maestro rural y marxista pedro castillo
pasará con la mayoría de los votos a la
segunda vuelta defendiendo un estado
fuerte y en contra de la explotación
laboral una oportunidad que agradeció a
sus votantes
muchas gracias mi perú hoy expreso mi
gratitud a todo el pueblo peruano muchas
gracias por el apoyo incondicional que
nos brindan en esta primera vuelta a
pesar de proceder de espectros políticos
completamente distintos ambos están en
contra de la igualdad de género del
matrimonio homosexual y del aborto por
lo que muchos ciudadanos no se sienten
representados por ninguno de los dos en
mitad de un punto crítico de la pandemia
los peruanos se preparan para una
segunda vuelta empañada por la
desconfianza política y la crisis
institucional en el país andino